hello uh my name is nagajan
so uh i'm going to uh it's a good
opportunity for me to actually talk at
this bio process virtual even
2020 and the title of the today's talk
is going to be
droplet digital pcr asset tool for gene
therapy application
so i just want to highlight one thing on
this title slide is
the image i put it in the title slide so
it's just the complexity
of how biologics have come up from a
small molecule
to a viral particle as well as a cell so
you can look at the size of these
molecules and how complexity
has been increased in this biological
world and the new technology that's
really required
to really answer this complex molly
so as a confidentiality statement today
most of this presentation is for
educational purpose
so any statements that are made like
forward looking statements or is mostly
from published literature
and uh not taken into assurance that
like this can be
becoming like a next uh like a uh
taking into consideration like these are
from literature
and don't really if these actual results
doesn't really
move forward as expected there will be
other factors in it
so the overview of the talk today is
like i'm going to
introduce you to gene therapy vectors
and i'm going to talk little
bit about the drug life cycle and i'm
also going to talk about
how analytical method development has
been involved into this drug development
and i will introduce you to the droplet
digital pcr
and i'll talk about like how the method
development really happens
and how do you really quantify uh
different
data on a digital docker pcr and i will
go ahead and talk about the
qualification and validation parameters
specifically for distributed pcr
in application to gene therapy and i'll
give my final thoughts
and some literature
so talking about gene therapy vector
so this pie chart has been i designed
this byte out
and this data is from the website that's
been put up by the gene medicine
so this actually shows you a landscape
of different viral vectors or vectors
that are really involved in gene therapy
clinical drawing
and this data is around like four years
back and
this landscape changed a lot and
primarily looking at the whole pie chart
the first things you can really observe
is like at navigate
retroviruses have been playing a
critical role uh
in this gene therapy trials i said there
are a bunch of other
vectors in viral that are also playing a
role were lengthy viruses and did no
associated viruses
and vaccinia virus but as said there
were also
other known viral vectors which also
play
a chunk of role which are like plasmid
and negative dna
so as said the landscape has completely
changed recently
increasing the royal number to lengthy
viruses and adenosine
viruses
so i want to talk about little bit about
the drug development cycle
so the drug development cycle includes
like a pregnancy interface
a phase one phase two and a phase three
and once you reach the phase three
you have an approval process and you go
from market
as said these all phases can also be
talked on the lines of a development
area so normally the early stage
development is considered to be a
preclinical and phase one
is considered to be an early development
at the early stage development whether
space 2 and phase 3
are considered to be a late stage
development whereas
once you have an approval and you go to
the market whatever
development happens is related to a
commercial development
and putting these prospective on a
manufacturing scale
you can say that so the pre-clinical to
phase one
still includes the research and
development of the biologic
whereas once you have a phase one uh
product ready
and you move into a phase two where
you're really looking at
a phase one done with efficacy and
safety studies and phase two is kind of
more a person so where you try to
develop these biologics
really bridging the r d product
transferring to
into a clinical good manufacturing
man clinical good manufacturing practice
so in which you try to develop this
product parameters of manufacturing
through an engineering process
so these are called engineering runs and
once you have
phase three product it should be
actually carried out using
under the gmp manufacturing once you
have an approval
and you are a commercial product you
ideally have to carry out through a
commercial manufacturing
so this is on looking at how
manufacturing takes place
and let's now look at like how an
analytical method development takes
place according to this all room
so as residual development initially a
specific biologic
can have its own essay it has to be
defined
it has to be designed at the same time
it has to be evaluated
and optimized so what it really means is
like really understanding
a biologic and what should be the
critical
parameter that should be like defined on
this biologic product
will be defined and designed and the
parameters of
to optimize the assay will be all done
during the restriction development
process
once you have an essay with kind of like
a variable parameters and that can be
like really showing some kind of
specificity to your biologic
you move into qualification the
qualification is a process where you
take this whole as a which has been in
the research stage
and you really look at like more
critical parameters like the specificity
of your
product as well as your linearity as
well as precision
and the range of quantification and this
helps to really most of your phase one
page two products are
qualified qualification as a products
that are being used
uh most of your assets have been
qualified by phase one and phase two but
as you move on to phase
three and like the approval process you
have to have the essay validated
the validation is a more robust process
in which you ideally take all the
parameters that have been performed in
qualification
and then you apply and other
situations like robustness as well as
the repeatability of the essay in
different conditions
so this where you really the essay is
being logged in
and really applied to very specific
biological problems
so once the validation is done you're
good to really send it for apla
and then you can do it for verification
so looking at what are the different
analytical assays in gene therapy for
viral vector
so when you look at a viral vector as i
said uh recently the landscape has
gained for most of the gene clinical
trials
have moved towards administrative virus
and lentiviruses so i'm going to focus
my talk i'm going to focus more
explaining them
so adversarial virus uh is a non-anal
virus and it has a genomic part and
protein
so the protein part is a gastric protein
which is made up of
like a vp123 and the genomic part is a
single standard dna
and when you come to lengthy virus it's
the angular virus
the amyloid virus has the capsid inside
in which the capsule
is like a p24 protein and
you have a single standard rna molecule
in the
virus so both these
viral vectors have different acids
because they have a protein part and
as well as the genomic part which is the
nucleic acid
so given the landscape of different
viruses and different assays that are
being applied
across in gene therapy looking at the
different vector
different assays you can get an idea
like edna accessory virus
has like a typefreshner say using a qpcr
or a digital pcr
where you ideally can ideally do a
titration using
hplc method and other an od method
and also as well as like a transgene
expression of like your infectivity
and the same way uh administrative virus
also has a bunch of assays which talk
about the specific genomic
uh material that it carries and the
protein
through analyzer and the potency as is
where the transgene is being expressed
and really looking at how much
infectivity is this water
and lentivirus also has a bunch of
essays on the similar lines which has
like genomic assay
genomic as well as the protein assay
so whatever highlighted in allo are very
specific
for the genomic acids because today's
talk is mostly towards
talking about distro pcr i want to
highlight like
what are the genomic assays that are
applied in
gene therapy
so there are different technologies for
this nucleic acid amplification
tool so in the field
the field has moved from pcr to
microarray microwave to sequencing
sequencing to nanospring nanospring
and the digital droplet pcr so a
quantity quantitative pcr
is a regular tachman pro pcr
where you have a standard and you're
ideally you're quantifying
your specific nucleic acid from a
relative standard curve
in a microarray you have a
so you use ideally extract your nucleic
acid and
probe them onto your chip and once you
have
a complementary probe with the
fluorophore is conjugated onto the probe
and you read that through a microarray
device
and sequencing is ideally you take the
genomic dna you just amplify based on
adapters and really look at like a
whole whole array of like nucleic acids
present
in the sample and nanostring has been a
new technology in which a specific
target dna
is being uh complementary complemented
by
two different probes so one of the probe
has a reporter gene
that has a complementarity that is an
anchor probe also has a complementarity
to your specific gene and the barcode is
breeded on a chip
and the good news with this technology
is like you don't really need
amplification
you just take your nucleic acid your
extracted nucleic acid and just put it
on the chip and you're able to read it
right away
so and the recent technology which i'm
going to highlight today
the crystal dr pcr the digital product
pcr is ideally similar to
quantitative pcr but where the ptr
happen
in in in individual droplets which are
like
the pcr is segregated into partitions
and which are
individual drop
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
like
each technology what are like what are
the different
uh parameters of each technology and
then
we can go ahead and discuss about the
distort proper pcr
so pretty much the parameters we
consider
here are like precision so precision is
kind of like how much accurate
uh can this as technology help us to
identify a specific target
so qpcr has a very high whereas like
microarray sequencing
as a very low because like these are not
specifically
uh amplification uh whereas noun string
also has a height because you have a
very high speed barcode specifically
and digital dropper pcr is very high in
precision because like it just
segregates your pcr and it has very less
effect of
inhibition or inhibitor and the number
of targets when you look at like
uh qpr and digital doppler pcr has a low
range
so when i mean that what i mean is like
you can only do a maximum
on digital pcr is like two amplicons
whereas qpcr you can do like four amp
so microarray sequencing or like they
just take they consider
random amplification so they are able to
amplify uh
a number of like target a nanostring
also has a high
uh because like you can create a lot of
complementarity probes to that so
throughput
when it comes to look at the throughput
throughput is the way how you can really
apply
n number of samples running at the same
time so
quantitative pcr has this high ability
because like it can
run around like 384 valves at one time
uh microarray sequencing and nanostring
are pretty low high throughput because
the only challenge they have is the
multiple steps in the protocol
which makes them like not applicable to
height
and digital doppler pcr is moderate it
still has a bunch of steps to do
but it can be done in a uh
in a repeatable way so absolute
quantification
when you're really looking at like exact
quantification
of a genomic title or putting into
consideration you can really say like
uh digital doppler pcr has became like a
very high
chance of because it doesn't really
depend on any standard curve
whereas qpcr depends on the standard
curve so the variability is higher
so the cost uh qpcr is the lowest
and digital pcr has to be moderate and
the other three technologies have been
very high
so talking about taking all these uh
different parameters and like giving us
like
more uh parameters giving us a idea
how digital dropper pcr can play uh i
just want to introduce like
how the flow can happen for a digital
droplet pcr
the digital pcr uh the flow
workflow happens through is kind of like
you have a sample preparation
in which the diluted sample is like
mixed with
the super mix and you prepare a digital
pcr plate
i've also played this prepared you seal
the plate and mix vigorously to mix your
sample
with the supermax and once you start
generating droplet
so you use this instrument called the
auto droplet generator
in which it has an oil and which feeds
the oil
through the vacuum into these cartridges
where your sample and the oil mix
together to form this droplet
so once you have a new plate with all
the droplets terminated you take the
plate and you seal the plate
and run your thermo cycler on a pcr
and once your pcr amplification
completes you
take the plate and start reading it
through your qx exploded
so the queued reader has like two uh
plurals which is called the famine hack
so
it's ideally similar to a flow cytometry
and each droplet is red
and it's given you a positive or a
negative sign so the positive normally
comes because of your hydrolysis of your
probe and you can
quantize software is used to carry out
analysis and report generation
so i said so each pcr each sample is
divided into twenty thousand droplets
and the pcr is carried around the
recycler
and you count the positive and the
negative droplet and ideally
it's an absolute quantification
so the principle involved in digital
doppler pcr
is position distribution so giving
an ideal situation so when you feed in
like x number of copies and you ideally
expect to see
like one target for one droplet but
that's not ideally
always the case in real scenario some
droppers can get like a high number of
uh genomic dna whereas the other doctors
will not
have anything it's a random process so
to really identify
it to really make this correction the
poisson
this position correction has been added
to really define
this concentration absolute
concentration
so looking at this uh graph here
so this one clearly shows your dynamic
range how
dynamic what's the dynamic range of the
digital pcr
so what you're looking at here on the
x-axis is just the fraction of positive
droplets
that can be present so ideally you have
a x number of positive droplets divided
by the total number of droplets
this is the values you're getting so on
the y-axis
uh the two y-axis on the left and right
and you see
the number of copies for droplet and the
number of
total drop total uh amount of dna
for 20 microwaves of the sample so as
you highly increase
uh droplet uh and you have like a
target copies for a droplet increases
when it's like
five and ideally you're reaching a
saturation of 10
10 000 copies uh in this whole reaction
so every droplet will have
a nucleic acid and where you don't have
a distribution of positive and negative
so ideally in scenarios people have
claimed that like your percentage
should be around like 0.7 or
0.6 to 0.8 to have a good ratio of
positive and negative top left
and as that this uh digital droplet pcr
has a high dynamic range which means
like
it can go even to like a low copy
it can read like around like one copy uh
per reaction that's what it really
claims
so normally you look at like once you
have a
digital droplet pcr happen you get an
amplitude plot
and you get like a positive and a
negative population so negative
population is counted as zero and a
positive population is counted as
one so the droplets uh
at least with one copy everything is
positive and more than one cup is also
so as you really increase your
uh the positive droplets have higher
intensity compared to
like fluorescence compared to negative
that's where you see this distribution
of these two populations and the
software takes into account the positive
and the negative population
and calculates the poisson correction
and gives you
the copper microliter
so after looking at all the poisson
distribution
so the critical factors we should be
taking care
to really develop this method on a
digital doctor pcr
is the first thing is really to look at
like sample preparation
so sample preparation plays a critical
role in digital pcr
so the first things people in literature
look look to really
kind of like optimize is the probe and
the primary concentration
so the probe concentration people have
played around from
to 62.5 to 250 nanomotor
and the primer people have played around
from 400 to 900
and as said this concentrations are
it's an average and people have played
little bit lower also
but this is kind of the range where most
of the studies have given
and moving on to the sample dilution
sample dilution plays a very important
role
so the amount of genomic dna you feed
into the reaction place very critical
role
so like an absolute quantification you
have to have
your positive and a negative population
as you feel like high amount of genomic
dna
uh it just segregates it just makes all
your droplets positive
so it's ideally important
for when you start optimizing this uh
initial method development
you should play around with different
concentration of your genomic dna and
that way
you can calculate back how many copies
per microliter you're feeding into the
reaction
and really find the linear range and
people have also tested like different
uh dilutes which again the buffer
or uh whichever buffer you are eluting
your nucleic acid in
and water has shown to be a very good
negative control
and as well as like a dilute for
destructive pcr and people use them a
lot
and the other set of the
whole distributor pcr which you need to
optimize would be
your pcr itself so the pcr itself
it really depends on ideally your
amplicon target amplicon you're really
doing so the people
uh once you have defined your target
amplicon you can really go check
on the cycling gradient in which you can
look at like from 30 to 45 cycles
you can play around with where you get a
nice distribution of positive negative
and then look at the amplitude
difference which where you should have a
very high amplitude
on the positive population and annealing
temperature
also plays a very critical role in
disrespectful pcr
uh the reason whatever you optimize on a
quantitative pcr may not always be
like transferred into adopted pcr
the reason why is like the ram speed on
the digital pcr
is kind of like lower because like these
are droplets each droplet has to be like
getting the same temperature so this
handling temperature on your primer
probe
also has to be like really
robustly checked before you optimized
your protocol for this pcr
and people tried around like 50 to 25
degrees
and that's like a range you can put like
do a
gradient on your amplicon daily identify
the best one
and sonication performing question is
ideally for like samples which you're
feeding like
a high amount of genomic dna you have a
very low target for example
so you ideally using sonication to
really disrupt the viscosity of your
genomic dna
people tested from three to three
seconds to communication and feedback
sound
digital pcr and people also use like
enhancers like the mso
or like wheel and that and these are
like kind of like helping
to really stop if any inhibitors are
like helping
uh for your semi-amplification to become
like
a completely amplified product and move
those whole
droplets into like a positive than
creating a big brain
so these are kind of like
recommendations people have used
to really establish the initial
pistol pcr method
and once you have an optimized method
and you run your whole digital pcr
protocol
and you're going to really receive uh on
your contrast of
software is like some kind of like uh
a value which is called copies per
microliter
the copy two microliter is the amount of
like
dna that's present per microliter and
ideally you have like 20 000 droplets
and you can ideally calculate back the
total concentration
or into 20 microliters and then you get
like a total amount of copies in the
whole reaction
but the important thing to really
consider is like the software actually
gives you like two different plot
so one is kind of an amplitude plot and
other is like a
1d histogram so both these things
there are a few things that we should be
really looking at the first thing
in a family and way is kind of like you
should have your
positive population and negative
population clearly defined
uh in such a way that like they're
separated very nicely
and you should not have any rain in
between if you have a lot of brain in
between it means like
your assay is not optimized to your
uh and
so the amplitude plot when you look at
like a histogram it's just like a
representation on a histogram where
you know your negative population and
your poster population are
completely uh placed on amplitude like
what's
the peak you're really looking at what's
the population height and everything
and there are different factors that
people take into consideration when
doing
a data interpretation so when you're
really doing
kind of a genomic hyper essay it's very
important to consider creating
kind of your lambda so lambda is kind of
like a log of like
how do you define like an optimal
concentration it's like
defining like exactly you're having a
half population of negative and half
population of positive
that's where you ideally have to be sure
uh to really get your genomic title out
so that's
that's been calculated through uh the
lambda where the negative population by
the total number of droplets
so when you have an acceptance of like
0.7
so it's been accepted that like you can
really take this value
and anything above this value you have
like a
mostly your population is ever nearly
around the
50 percent positive and negative and you
can really get tighter out of it and
respect more robust
and annealing temperature and primal
probe concentration also play a very
important role as i mentioned
so that is can be based on the
resolution between the positive and the
negative
so that people have calculated using
another
parameter called separation so you take
the amplitude of the positive minus the
amplitude of the negative by
amplitude of the negative and like which
will give you like if
the separation is ideally more than
1.5 it's considered to be like very
high resolution so which means like
you're not reading any kind of like
uh everything the power positive and the
new populations are separated very good
so the ideal temperature gradient has
also been shown
equal to 52 people have in literature
and a lot of like
it again depends on the target amplifier
also at the same time
so the other two factors for the
reaction performance people have added
to look at is like the peak resolution
so ideally the peak resolution
is a factor that's been taken from the
chromatography hplc
methods it's kind of like really
considering
like the height of the peak and the
distance of the peak between the two
populations
and really looking like if they are
separated and
if the value is like more than 2.5
it's considered to be like everything
red
on the positive population is completely
positive so that's where
you get a peak resolution and the
percentage of
rain is also important as i mentioned
previously so if you have a lot of rain
between your positive and negative
it completely increases a lot of
variability and what you're reading
uh can be like complete have a lot of
variability in your reading and which
means like your essay is not really
optimized to your specific template
so this again these are like thought
like uh very critical to look at
like when you're really designing
android optimizing
your distributor pcr uh initial method
and as you have like a more robust
method
once you develop like you can like not
really considered
in the initial phases it's important to
construct all these parameters
so stepping like
on to the next steps and talking about
like a critical characteristic
like till now we talked about like how
can you develop a
method on digital pcr now we want to
really look at like
what are the critical parameters as i
mentioned once you have an essay
that's been like on your research rate
you want to move into
more kind of like a qualification and a
validation scale on a digital pcr
if you have an essay on sscale how do
you move them
uh into a qualification so so once you
want to move an essay into qualification
and validation so these are like
critical parameters that have been
mentioned
on fta website like
which you have to really consider like
sensitivity specificity accuracy
precision range you need to understand
the rank unlimited quantification
and robustness and limit of protection
so
pretty much like these are like all the
important parameters
that should be like very precisely
defined for an assay
to really move that essay into god
really carry out these
qualifications process so i'm going to
talk about like
the essay qualification for the digital
droplet pcr
what are the recommendations in
literature and how should you really
look at
so when i say as a qualification most of
the essay
on a research scale one has to be like
more into phase one
applying a qualification so it should be
fit for
first things would be like okay uh
digital droplet pcr did you already find
it
so it fit the purpose and then
the first critical thing you should be
really looking at like is the essay
really capable of producing
repeatable results uh for the specific
purpose so
you have a specific amplicon you want to
really look at this amplifon
in a specific set of samples and these
are really producing the same
amount same specific result uh as
this essay is done on different number
of
samples and again this should be
performed at least by
two analysts you really come from like
okay essay is fit people
so going on like and talking about like
what the critical parameters that should
be considered
and what are the acceptance criteria for
the digital topic pcr essay
uh for a qualification so the first
things
we can look at is the specificities the
specificity is kind of like
really answering the point on the
digital draft on an essay
is okay we have a specific target
and whatever we did is designed to
really identify the specific target
very precisely that's called so to
really do these experiments what
uh one of the best experiments to do
that is to really look at like
taking a non-specific non-target
sample and really checking that like
there is no background noise on your
specific amplicon happen
so you just want to be so specific that
whatever your primal probes you design
on this distal pcr you just want to be
sure like it's not really uh amplifying
anything
on a non-target sample and you can also
take your
target sample and make it heat
inactivated or nuclear digested
and really use the same primer probe and
really check out like
okay if you digest our everything out
are you really
able to pick anything so this really
answers like on the
distal pcr is like okay whatever we
design
is very specific to the specific uh
target what we want to really do
in the essay so that's that's kind of
like your specificity and you can run
multiplexing and single collecting
settings
on your digital pcr to real issue uh
nothing is
kind of like interfering with your
target amplifon
and when you go look at the validation
when you really have an essay on a
digital pcr and you want to really do
specifically on a validation scale
the first things what people have done
is take a blank sample
and we really run like
your specific template on and really see
like there's nothing been amplified
and people have also taken blank samples
and spiked your specific target into it
at the lowest limit of quantification
the lowest limit you identify
you just spike in such amount of and
really run
multiple times and really show that like
in this essay
and the second thing we can look at is
accuracy so accuracy is kind of like
you have a target and you know like this
target has been
really your digital pcr really works for
this specific target
so you want to to check for accuracy
what we can do is like you can
do a multiple runs of your essay for the
same target
or do a repetitive sampling and really
identify like
when you feed in a specific amount of
target
into your reaction you're reading out
the same concentration
that's called accuracy so how do
people have done using spiked in control
so take a plasmid
spike into a background and really check
like what's your record
and you can people have also used like
specific amplicon integrated cell lines
to really look at like your accuracy is
clearly measured
on a copy number variation right
and then so for the qualification what
we
do for the accuracy is like you can run
all multiple instruments so
you have a digital pcr in your site you
can go for pro
run the same accuracy experiment on a
different and
look at like how much are you getting
what's the exact
value are you are you able to get the
same exact value
and the accuracy is like always defined
to 88 120
and the cv should be once you do a
variable tissue
less than 20 so when you go into
validation the validation you ideally
take it
takes up to five levels you really
consider
the assay of the analyte or the
amplicon you can consider to be like it
consider the lowest limit of
quantification the highest limit of
quantification and you do kind of like
other limit of quantification controls
you take like three different
quantification controls
and really run everything on different
instruments
and really define for the pcr
is accuracy it's like okay the specific
accuracy
for a specific target from six
independent runs
would be like your accuracy could be
like 120 80 to 120
and always your cv should be less than
20 to be sure it passes
if not like you have to go back and
re-analyze the redo it
so linear so linearity on displaypcr
is similar to what you see on qpcr you
ideally take
a linearized plasmid your target
amplicon and a plasmid
and you do kind of exterior dilution of
it from
a five-fold dilution or seven-fold
dilution do a linear curve
and just run it on digital pcr and
identify the range
what's the highest uh you would be
ideally
confident and the lowest you're getting
like less
variability and people have done spikens
like take a plasmid of your target and
spike it into a non-specific background
and do linearity experiments and really
look at like how much
uh what's the linearity you're able to
really recover
do your recovery and what you ideally
identify as like 80 to 120 is acceptable
and you just have in qualification you
just have to repeat it three times
so range of quantification is kind of
like another
uh to identify the range so once you
define your linearity so you will get
like a
upper limit of quantification and the
lower limit of quantification
of your specific amplifier so you take
the same
upper limit of quantification and the
lower limit of quantification
and you subdivide that upper limit of
quantification into like
uh six different concentrations on the
higher range
and subdivide them and then run them
and really identify like what's the
highest and the lowest
of your exact uh
the quantification you can really
identify your target
so in this way you're defining very
precisely what is the highest
upper limit and the lowest lower limit
of your
specific amplicon that can be in
linearity
and so that's called the range of your
quantification so
in qualification uh it's been tested
like three different
multiple instruments at the same time is
defined as your recovery should be like
80 to 120.
so so these are kind of like defined for
as a qualification on the digital
property pcr and moving on
we can talk about like as a validation
so as a validation is a comprehensive
moment as i mentioned previously
so it actually evaluate all the
documentation
what which has been done in
qualification and
take all those qualification parameters
and really
add few more parameters onto this
assay to really check for like intro as
a variability
interlaboratory assessment and how much
is this asset repeatable and how much
robust is this and in this case
normally on qualification two analysts
done this experiment
two instruments is acceptable but in
validation it should be done
with at least three analysts and three
different instruments
and very precise so on a digital pcr
essay so when you ideally want to
have kind of like you have an essay
it has been qualified and now you want
to really validate it
in such a way that the essay can be
presented towards like a bla
that's concerned so primarily people
have looked at is the robustness of the
essay so what is actually meant by
rubbish noise is like
does this as they can cope up with any
small changes
that has been applied to the assay so as
said
so we can so normally a control
spike in control can be used or your
specific target
uh in either form it can be used as a
control to do this experiments
so people have done like testing on your
digital uh pcr protocol like your essay
on different instruments doing it with
different operators
and people have tested like five
different primal probe concentrations
what is that range
it is really robust like uh you can and
really show that like it still gives you
the same
uh specificity same value as accuracy
and you can also test like
eight different temperatures like x
number and temperatures and really show
that like this is the range
of like uh once you identify an alien
temperature you go
like very minor changes on the uh
and healing temperature and you can
define the range
of like where this is so robust and
on a validation point of view the
recovery should be around like
80 to 120 and this should be like done
at least three times
and this important other important thing
is stability
so stability is kind of like uh
invalidation stability plays the
critical role because like because
stability of the reagent stability of
the reagents and the assay
step each step in the essay is
thoroughly
validated is thoroughly
looked at to really answer like how much
this assay is stable
and how this assay operates between
different
uh time at different areas the first
first things on stability for the
digital pcr protocol
or like an essay can be really looked at
is like
the conditions for thor of nsa reagents
so they should be done at room
temperature or they can be done at 4
degree
or you know these these are temperature
gradients that you can really call
and really see like how much stable are
these reagents at this different thought
conditions
and you can also look at like the
restore stability of reagent
or you pre-start it put it back and you
do kind of like multiple spray stops and
look at this reagents like how much
till how many runs these reagents are
more stable in this freestyle
and the time between droplet generation
and pcr cycling how much time
can be left on the plate in such way
that the
droplets don't start mixing with each
other to form big droplets because this
is another critical important part of
stability on prop
pcr where people uh when you want to
really transparent as they
into validation has to be considered
and the other is the time from once
you've done your
pcr cycling and transferring the whole
plate for droplet reading
and people have tested this at different
temperatures people when you put at room
temperature
uh they start like colors the droplets
start
mixing with each other from bigger
droplets to uh putting at four degrees
they're more stable so but like again
looking at
like what's the longer temperature on
your specific
digital pcr essay how is that applicable
for validation these are these are
things should be looked at
and again i said this should be like
done
at least three times pre-analyzed and as
that
each condition has to be done in three
different experiments so if you're doing
like
uh four different parameters you're
checking out then each you will have
like three different experiments it's
like a collectively like fallback
comments
that's what you really mean so
boom and once i
talk about like all the validation i
would like to talk more about the
comparable studies
because the reason why most of the
essays
have been really optimized on
quantitative pcr
as droplet digital pcr has been a new
technology that's coming in
so talking from the point of a vital
vector
in gene therapy the primary essays
people really
use um quantitative pcr is the genomic
assays
and in which the two different essays
people really want to use
these qp sha methods is like a viral
vector determination
or a copy number variation or how much
amount of this specific virus is present
on a background so that's kind of like
understanding
how many this it can be called a title
also
so as you have an essay that's been
developed in
pcr in a research grade and you also
qualified that as they for phase one
but you ideally have this new technology
of drop requests for pcr
and how do you bridge these for the
previous sample
and how do you apply this top register
pcr as you move forward for validation
or phase b
study so the best way to do this listing
study
in literature people have suggested is
like one thing is like ideally to
save samples like if you have samples
from
your you know phase one or the
pre-clinical
save those samples and use the same
samples that you ran qpcr
run them on digital pcr and really
identify
what the value you're getting you know
that that is a very good
way of really doing the bridging initial
study
and then you can define variability of
these methods like okay
both methods are completely different
because they use uh different steps
and different polymerases and you you
have to identify uh
if the variability between your title is
like three to
four two to three four so it's it's
ideally accepted in
by through fba that luggage it can be
answered
so that's something once again it
changes from amplicon to amplify
that's the key thing you have to really
be defined we considered
and people have also shown like people
already have a qpcr essay and they want
to go into digital pcr they found out
like with the standard
they took like a specific
uh kind of a standard material and they
ran both of them simultaneously and they
found like a conversion factor
where qpcr adding this conversion factor
gets to the same value as the digital
pcr
the digital pcr is like an absolute
quantification and you have a higher
value
on the distribution so i said
uh the second thing would be running
sample
side by side and both the essay take a
sample run side by side on the buses
but and really identify uh what is the
critical step
that may cause this variability because
like there are there are
studies where people have talked about
like uh restriction
reverse transcriptase on a digital pcr
compared to qpcr
reverse transcriptase plays the timing
60 minutes
qpcr is 5 minutes and you have this huge
title variation when you increase the
600 qpcr
you exactly get the same value so people
have shown these kind of steps so it's
kind of like taking your sample
run them side by side and really
identify like what is that
critical step that can cause variability
between these two aspects so these are
kind of bridging essays
but i said there's also challenges right
like so what are the challenges would be
like
you may not have enough sample like okay
you have around these samples
qpcr and phase one but you may not have
once you want to transfer into digital
pcr
so ideally you the best way is to really
use some kind of like
uh standard material that you use
in both the essays and really identify
them so
so critical process parameters may not
be known so what it really means is like
uh if you really consider like accuracy
or like precision or range of
quantification these are things may not
be defined for your specific design
amplicon which will be really important
to consider uh which may be defined on a
qpcr but it may be
you'll be required to define on your
digital docker pcr
so and we know like qpcr
has this ability to get like inhibitors
can play a big role because it's a bulk
reaction
so whereas digital droplet pcr has shown
like
more robustness towards like impurities
and inhibitory factors so this is
something to consider
when you're really moving from qpcr to
twitter why the fighter is like higher
i mean absolute pc and displaypcr
is these are these are things to
identify what are the impurities that
play a role
and okay this important thing would be
limited as a development like you might
not have
a good reference for your application
that is something
you might have to really go and
establish you know
uh that might limit your understanding
or your bridging study between
quantitative easing
but again these are thoughts like you
know taking in from literature and
giving putting their
like thoughts like how can you really
define and answer the important
things so the final thought would be
like
you know digital pcr is kind of like and
it has like a it's an absolute
quantification
so it really doesn't depend on a
standard curve to give a value
and it can also have the stability
if you have a low uh the sensitivity is
on the lower level is much higher so it
can really go
uh very low as like people on literature
claim to one copy
so that's to be considered and
so it's another thing is like as i
mentioned it's tolerant to pcr
inhibitors because like it's kind of
like individual reaction and droplet
and that that's something is also very
critical
so any small change in expression
because it's not a bulk reaction
it's in a droplet so that change can be
like identified immediately
even the semi amplification will give
you a positive uh droplet consider
whereas like in a qpc the bulk it may
not be like
completely like picked up in this bulk
reactor
so that's another important
so i said so these are some of the
references
uh to go ahead and really look at and
this gives you a very good uh overview
of like qpcr digital vcr and again these
are like more related to
um gene therapy and virology but
this can be a good starting point and i
would like to
um acknowledge by uh texas a m
university
giving the opportunity to do my graduate
degree and lonza
and sana from providing me my scientific
training right now
so and i would like i would like to
thank
lab rats lab roots for providing me this
good opportunity to provide this talk
and thank you